Originally, I create the list by using add. And now I want to insert an element
without wiping away anything. I can't just use the add method because that
would add it on to the end of a list and I want to put it in the middle. So
I'll specify the index where I want to add it. So the index I would want is
two. Now I always forget whether the index or the element comes first, but
that's okay, I can always check. All I have to do is search for ArrayList, Java
7, go to the official documentation, and I know what method I'm looking for, so
I'll search, for add, and here I can see the index comes before the element. So
the index I wanted was two. And I'm adding another book. And now when I run the
demo it'll print The Eyre Affair, Night Watch, followed by zebras and then
next, just like I asked.